este es uno de los dos cráteres que dejó
un ataque esta madrugada en este patio
de uno de los colegios de la ciudad de
gramatosa quienes hicieron ya las
investigaciones preliminares dicen que
este cráter tiene 10 metros de diámetro
y según también por los restos de los de
los misiles que han encontrado aseguran
que podrían ser misiles s 300
enviado bolsas rusas esta madrugada no
fueron los únicos en la ciudad se
sintieron varios ataques pero para los
pobladores
Esto no es nuevo estos ataques vienen
dándose desde el comienzo de la invasión
a gran escala pero se han hecho mayores
en los últimos meses en la medida que
esa batalla por la población de muy
lejos de aquí se intensifica las
autoridades dicen que el frente de
batalla solamente está a 20 kilómetros
de la ciudad y ellos cada vez están
preparando para una posible
acercamiento de las tropas rusas Ellos
dicen que confían plenamente en la
fortaleza de las tropas ucranianas para
detener que se muevan hasta aquí
solamente para todavía el 80% de vacuno
como tienen ahora duraron 10 meses y
ellos creen que Ucrania está mucho más
fortalecido en este momento para que
esto no suceda pero lo que no pueden
evitar son esos ataques constantes
combustibles
[Música]
rescatar Cómo se han ido preparando
durante estos meses cada vez que hay un
ataque como este a las cinco de la
madrugada ya había personas limpiando
las calles
los que hago hasta ahora todo se
moviliza para intentar volver a dejar la
ciudad de una cierta normalidad